you know our position will continue to
be we want structural changes here we
want structural changes on all the items
theft of the IP the force transfers of
Technology cyber hacking of course trade
barriers we've got to have something
that's enforceable I'm not sure you know
your price they all have a good
conversation at the top they'll have
their own those well I don't know in
economic terms the burden of these
tariffs so far I think a strong case can
be made it falls more heavily on China
and we're actually seeing evidence
China's had their companies they're
losing market share so a lot of
importers in the US can go elsewhere
there's a lot of elasticity of demand
that you could pardon that economists
phrase don't have to buy from China
that's one point China seems to be
slashing their prices so they're losing
money that's another part as I've said
many many times I think the president
Hunter sent write all the unfair non
reciprocal trading practices which China
has got to change
it's got to change they've been breaking
world trading laws a long time to our
disadvantage hurting our economy hurting
our workers so it's got to change so I
think any cost-benefit ratio works out
very well for the president in terms of
the economic burden
we feel the bigger part of that burden
will come with a China size because
because number one if they want to sell
into the tariffs are gonna have to slash
prices which means they will lose money
and damage their number to some American
firms have already begun actions to
shift production from China to the
United States number three the pardon my
phrase elasticity's of demand American
customers of China products don't have
to stay with China they can go to
Vietnam Bangladesh Mexico so that's
where the economic burden we believe
Falls most heavily on the Chinese
it's really hard to say and I didn't
want to speculate the two leaders will
talk that's all I know and as I said our
team insists on as I just described its
structural changes long-lasting and
forcible structural changes that's all I
can possibly say